Naomi's in Chicago hi Naomi welcome to
the Dave Ramsey show hello
so glad to be speaking with you you too
how can we help
well we watch your book baby steps Total
Money Makeover several years ago and my
husband was you know let's do this
well that went by the wayside somehow
we've been married for 30 years and we
have now gotten ourselves one hundred
three thousand five hundred seven
dollars and five cents in debt again
between some owns three credit cards a
home equity loan a boat and a bed
we kind of went on a little spending
free when our son died because we were
looking for we were looking for
happiness in all the wrong places I
guess you could say a lot of people to
Greece spending what happened here on
hold was he he was 31 and he had a heart
condition
I'm sure when did he pass July 16 so
it'll be three years okay so I used to
hear when I was growing up that about
90% of solving a problem is realizing
there is one okay you just told me
there's a problem we went on a spending
spree some of it was grief related which
isn't it doesn't make you a bad person
it just means that you you know went
through a hard time and you managed it
the wrong way but that's okay we were
just makes you human
okay I get it and so now but we don't
have to look in the rearview mirror it's
smaller than the windshield you can
glance at it and say that's what
happened now let's look out the
windshield so what are you gonna do
about all this well my question is we
did baby steps before from the book do
we need to go back to the book or is
Financial Peace University better to do
we need a budgeting tools well every
dollar plus is a part of Financial Peace
University and it ties to your bank and
that's the budgeting tool Financial
Peace University is the best thing on
the planet to solve this problem but
guess what none of that's going to help
unless you're done
you're never going back know you're
wasting your time to go to the gym if
you're going to overeat and gain the
weight back
right so you got to be skinny from now
on right that was part of my wake-up
call was I had been using food as well
but have a missus for 30 years I've been
the quote-unquote budgeters
and my husband had been B Thunder well
this is not work so are we ready to
change Financial Peace University and
the baby steps are the way to fix this
but they don't work unless you do yeah
they don't work unless you as a couple
do you and your husband do so will he go
to Financial Peace University this time
can we do that online in our reason
because we live in the middle of nowhere
we don't give it to you as a
subscription for a year and give you the
class and that includes every dollar and
includes the online membership where you
can watch everything but honey you can't
do this by yourself it's not gonna work
mr. spender boy has to be on the plan
with you or you're gonna crash again
it's okay that you have fallen off the
wagon now get back on but get back on